Probably in terms of writing and linguistic
awareness there were a combination, firstly
of W’s, P.G.
Woodhouse, Oscar Wilde and Evelyn Waugh, the
British novelist.
That’s a male Evelyn by the way.
And I would add to that Arthur Chonan Doyle,
the author of Sherlock Holmes.
When I was between the ages of about seven
and twelve I was obsessed with Sherlock Holmes
and I would read and reread and re, re, reread
all those, so the rhythms and tones of the
English language as exemplified by that kind
of grand perfect Victorian manner and then
Dickens, but it was really Oscar Wilde who
awoke language in my head in a way like nobody
else and I think also discovering the kind
of man Oscar Wilde was, was an enormous influence
as well.
The fact that you could be such a towering
intellect, such a lord of language and be
charming and graceful, kind, good natured,
but also unhappy and unlucky was a great discovery
for an adolescent because one of the traps
of adolescence is the sort of paranoid resentment
that somehow you’re never going to match
up and that everybody else’s life is going
to be better and finer and fuller.
That everyone else attended some secret lesson
in which how to live was taught and you had
a dental appointment that day or you were
somehow not invited and the point of great
writers like Wilde is that they make that
invitation to you.
They welcome it.
Perhaps the greatest definition I think of
character and quality is people who when they’re
truly great rather than making you feel that
tall they make you feel that tall, that they’re
greatness as it were improves you.
They used to say of Oscar Wilde that when
you got done from a dinner table you felt
funnier and wittier and cleverer.
Now a lot of Brilliant people make you feel
less funny, less clever, less witty because
they’re so clever, witty and funny, but
he had the opposite effect.
A bit like what Shakespeare said about Falstaff,
not just a wit, but a cause of wit in others.
Philosophy is an odd thing.
When we use the word in everyday speech you
know you sometimes hear it hilariously.
They say, “Oh, it’s never good to be late.”
“That’s my philosophy.”
You think that’s a generous description
of that rather dull precept to call it a philosophy,
but it’s odd how philosophers generally
speaking, at least the ones I’ve read or
the ones I you know value, don’t have in
that sense a philosophy.
There is no particular Socratic or Dimechian
or Kantian way to live your life.
They don’t offer ethical codes and standards
by which to live your life.
They don’t offer a philosophy to follow.
They just simply raise an enormous number
of questions mostly, so in the sense that
you put the question is there a philosopher
that’s important to me.
Well I me I loved really the sort of the Bertrand
Russell grand sort of tour of philosophy,
the history of philosophy from the pre Socratics
as they’re called, Zeno and so on through
to Socrates and Plato and Aristotle.
I never quite liked Aristotle.
I think that’s partly…
Although he was obviously a genius and brilliant
and he invented logic, so what’s not to
like.
I think it was his influence on the medieval
mind was probably rather pernicious and unfortunate
and all those categories and things, but when
it opened up with I suppose Spinoza and them,
but then Kant and the enlightenment era.
Oh and actually Locke.
I did like Locke.
He was a fine philosopher, but they don’t…
I mean what is so great about them is that
they just…
They’re quite scary when you think of the
word philosopher and especially if it’s
logic and symbolic logic and it gets onto
Hegelian philosophies, incredibly difficult
to read I find and you follow it for about…
Well it’s like trying to grab a salmon.
You know the harder you clutch at it the more
it springs, slips out of your hand and whoa,
it’s gone and you chase it again and what
was that and you feel very stupid, but the…
I think the beauty of questioning and simplicity
that you get from Kant in particular I think
is just amazing because it’s like they say
of simple mathematical laws that make fractals,
the tiniest little elegant observation about
or question about something just spins out
these immensely complex things that make you
rethink everything.
So yes, I think philosophy is a really important
dimension, but I think in our age we tend
to be rather sloppy about it.
We either think Buddhism is philosophy, which
you know or some sort of eastern thing about
being nice and spiritual and that will do,
which it’s fine.
I mean you know obviously I believe in kindness
and niceness and lots of spiritual things,
but the real intellectual rigor and quest
of logic is something that I’m afraid takes
incredibly hard work and we live in an age
in which hard work is if not actively deprecated
or denigrated it is run away from or ignored.
It’s sort of people frown at you and say,
“Well, that’s a bit dull and stupid.
Why can’t we just short circuit it and talk
about like spirit?”
Well yeah, you can say spirit, but if you
think that’s philosophy and if you think
that’s good enough.
The most important philosophy I think is that
even if it isn’t true you must absolutely
assume there is no afterlife.
You cannot for one second I think, abbragate
the responsibility of believing that this
is it because if you think you’re going
to have an eternity in which you can talk
to Mozart and Chopin and Schopenhauer on a
cloud and learn stuff and you know really
get to grips with knowledge and understanding
and so you won’t bother now.
I think it’s a terrible, a terrible mistake.
It may be that there is an afterlife and I’ll
look incredibly stupid, but at least I will
have had a crammed pre afterlife, a crammed
life, so to me the most important thing is
you know as Kipling put it, to fill every
60 seconds with you know what is it?
To fill every unforgiving minute with 60 seconds
worth of distance run.
You know absolutely, so that’s all I’m
saying I suppose.
Is that there is no point wasting time being
lazy, though of course indolence in a divine
way, actually has its advantages.
Oh, shut up Steve.
Okay, next one.
It’s interesting.
Atheism comes into rather a bad press and
I suppose I’d rather describe myself as
a humanist, who human…
I don’t believe in God.
I don’t believe there is a God.
If I were to believe in a god l would believe
in gods.
I think monotheism is the really ghastly thing.
That is the absolutely staggering to me misapprehension.
I can perfectly see why anybody might imagine
that each thing, each thing that grows, each
phenomenon that we… that accompanies us
on our journey through life, the sky, the
mountains, spirits of nature.
I can imagine why man would wish to endow
them with an inner something, an inner animus
that they would call the god of that thing.
I can see that.
It’s a beautiful and charming way of looking
at it and I can understand the Greek idea
that there are these you know these principles
of lightening or of war or of wisdom and to
embody them, to personify them into a Athena
or Aries or whichever god you want makes enormous
sense, but to say that there is one only god
who made it all and who is…
Yeah, that is just…
What?
Why?
Who said?
Where?
Come on.
And I love how when people watch I don’t
know, David Attenborough or Discovery Planet
type thing you know where you see the absolute
phenomenal majesty and complexity and bewildering
beauty of nature and you stare at it and then…
and somebody next to you goes, “And how
can you say there is no God?”
“Look at that.”
And then five minutes later you’re looking
at the lifecycle of a parasitic worm whose
job is to bury itself in the eyeball of a
little lamb and eat the eyeball from inside
while the lamb dies in horrible agony and
then you turn to them and say, “Yeah, where
is your God now?”
You know I mean you got…
You can’t just say there is a God because
well, the world I beautiful.
You have to account for bone cancer in children.
You have to account for the fact that almost
all animals in the wild live under stress
with not enough to eat and will die violent
and bloody deaths.
There is not any way that you can just choose
the nice bits and say that means there is
a God and ignore the true fact of what nature
is.
The wonder of nature must be taken in its
totality and it is a wonderful thing.
It is absolutely marvelous and the idea that
an atheist or a humanist if you want to put
it that way, doesn’t marvel and wonder at
reality, at the way things are, is nonsensical.
The point is we wonder all the way.
We don’t just stop and say that which I
cannot understand I will call God, which is
what mankind has done historically.
That’s to say God was absolutely everything
a thousand or two thousand years ago because
we understood almost nothing about the natural
world, so it could all be God and then as
we understood more God receded and receded
and receded, so suddenly now he is barely
anywhere.
He is just in those things we don’t understand,
which are important, but I think it just is
such an insult to humanity and the Greeks
got it right.
The Greeks understood perfectly that if there
were divine beings they are capricious, unkind,
malicious mostly, temperamental, envious and
mostly deeply unpleasant because that you
can say well yes, all right, if there is going
to be god or gods then you have to admit that
they’re very at the very least capricious.
They’re certainly not consistent.
They’re certainly not all loving.
I mean really it’s just not good enough.
You know if we empower ourselves with responsibility
over our actions, responsibility over our
destinies and responsibility for directing
and maintaining and creating our own ethical
and moral frameworks, which is the most important
thing really isn’t it because perhaps the
greatest insult to humanism is this idea that
mankind needs a god in order to have a moral
framework.
There is a very clear way of demonstrating
logically how absurd that is because the warrant
for that logical framework, for that moral
framework that comes from God is always tested
against man’s own morals and it’s a complicated
argument, but I mean that’s you know it’s
the standard one which is pretty unanswerable,
but the idea that we don’t know right from
wrong, but we have to take it from words put
down in a book two, three, four, five, six
thousand years ago and dictated to rather
hotheaded neurotic desert tribes is just insulting.
It’s just no, I mean you know if there were
a God he would want us to be better spirited
than to take his word for everything.
Wouldn’t he?
If he gave us free will would he really want
us to say, “No, I have to abide by everything
that’s written in this book, all the laws
of circumcision and of eating and of… and
what to do with menstruating women?”
I mean, “I’m going to obey those written
down there.
“ “I won’t think for myself because
that’s not required of me.”
Come on.
It’s just not good enough and you know I
have no quarrel with individuals who wish…
who are devout and who have faith.
I don’t want to mock them.
I really don’t, but damned if I’m going
to be told by them what to do with my body
or damned if I’m going to have the extraordinary
battles won by enlightenment over the past
400 years, to have those battles abdicated
by a new dark ages.
It’s you know.
The battle lines must be drawn.
Music in its time, but I mean that’s a function
of history you know.
The fact is that composers always write for
the power because… or power and money and
it so happened that in the period when polyphony
all the way through to the classical and early
romantic era all the power and the money was
with the church, so some great masses and
some great choir music and some great oratories
were written from obviously the Baroque age
being the sort of pinnacle of that, but all
the way through to Mozart’s final works
and his requiem and Beethoven’s Missa solemnis
and Mendelssohn and so on.
There have been some marvelous religious works
and in paintings similarly, but that’s because
these were princes.
They were princes of the church.
They were prince arch bishops who employed
Mozart.
These were not spiritual beings who inculcated
these composers with a sense of the divine
that makes the music divine.
The glory of Verde’s requiem or Mozart’s
requiem or Bach’s pieces is that they are
fantastic, incredibly human and like all great
human’s thing they reach for the infinite.
They reach for beauty.
A religious person would call that the divine.
You could call it the humanist.
You could call it anything else, but certainly
is that.
Religion has been good for that and good for
architecture because it is required that enormous…
It required enormous buildings for the shepherding
of people in, in order to do the services
and they spend a lot of money on it and so
they are rather glorious buildings.
You’ve got to hand them that.
Do they make the trains run on time?
No, they didn’t do that.
That’s about it really.
And there are some kind individual people.
I mean very kind people who give to the poor
and look after the sick and so on, but it’s
not necessary and sufficient as a justification
for religion because there are plenty of people
who are not religious who are also kind to
the sick and good to the poor and care about
people’s wellbeing.
Yes, very much so.
I mean Trevor Huddleston and Arch Bishop Tutu
from South Africa are two good examples who
were both genuine men of their church or let
me see.
Huddleston is dead, but Tutu is still alive
and who both fought a terrible injustice and
used all the authority of their position amongst
their believers and but very bravely spoke
out and sometimes against the wishes of the
church hierarchies.
Some liberation rheologist who are from you
know some of them mad communists, some of
them just decent liberals who fought against
the hideous doctrines of the Roman Catholic
church for example and there are individual
voices who are raised in conscious against
the bureaucracy and the dogma and the doctrine
of the churches and you know certainly of
course individuals in you know Bonheoffer
for example in Germany, the Lutheran minister
who spoke out against Hitler.
There are…
Of course there have been good and fine religious
people and the Dolly Llama seems rather charming.
I don’t know.
It’s terrible.
I don’t want to come over as some terrible
anti ecclesiastical figure, but.
I came from what on the surface would have
looked like a very typical English family
in as much as I say a typical one that an
American might regard as typical.
It was a country house with gardeners and
nice staff and it looked rather grand and
I was sent away at the age of seven to a prep
school, which in England is from seven to
thirteen is prep school, sent away to boarding
school two hundred miles from home and that
sort of again was very traditional English.
What you might call an upper class, upper
middle class sort of education and where I
received a very classical education.
My parents were marvelously educated people.
They’re both university educated, both brilliant
scholars in Irwin, my father a physicist,
my mother historian, but not absolutely typical
of the class because my mother’s family’s
Jewish.
She is European Jewish and she was…
She was born in Britain, but her sister was
born in the family area, which is now Slovakia,
but which was Hungary and indeed for a short
time, Czechoslovakia and so there was that
sort of mixture, that rather exotic mixture,
the mother’s family of people who talked
about food, which was a very an un-English
thing to do back in the sixties when I was
growing up into.
We had that kind of exotic accent and all
those things, but they weren’t Judaic.
They weren’t religiously Jewish.
They were just proud to be Jewish Jews and
there were plenty of them in Israel.
Those who had survived the Holocaust were
in Israel or most in America and so in that
sense it was a…
It was an idyllic childhood looking at the
house and looking at how lucky we were it
looks fantastic, but of course the childhood
is what goes on inside your head, nothing
to do with what goes on outside, so it was
the usually sticky mess of adolescent Sturm
und Drang.
Always closest to my mother because my mother
is an extraordinarily warm and unbelievably
friendly and loveable person.
People are genuinely astounded by her, her
positivity.
She is just the most smiling person people
will have met.
And so that you know obviously gave you know
closest warmth.
My father was rather remote.
I thought of him…
I wrote about this in my autobiography that
I thought of him as Sherlock Holmes.
He was similarly a deeply rational man and
unbelievably brilliant you know because of
his physics and his mathematics and also music.
As a young boy he was a choral student at
St. Paul’s Cathedral and played piano beautifully
and his musical understanding was very fine
and but very sort of great intellectual rigor.
He seemed to us as children, to my brother
and my sister and myself as quite cold and
quite forbidding, quite frightening.
He worked incredibly hard.
He worked at home.
The stable block of the family house, which
was a very large stable block indeed was he
converted to his laboratory is where he worked
and so he…
You know we never had the pleasure of him
being out of the house.
I mean he was inside the house in his study
working you know working and we never quite
knew where he was and if we made a noise we
felt sort of thunder rumbling, so he was quite
a scary man and now of course on very easy
fine terms, but it was a difficult, difficult
thing.
What makes a good family?
Well, I suppose obviously love.
Love lubricated often I think by humor.
I think a family that can laugh at each other
and tease themselves and who are able to be
jolly with each other I think is the key.
Humor is you know like a dog’s tongue or
dog’s nose rather, which should be cold
and faintly wet and a vet will tell you that’s
a sign of a healthy dog.
I think our equivalent of a cold wet nose
is humor.
Families where there is not much laughter
I think are signs of some sort of dysfunctionality
or sickness.
Maybe if there is too much laughter it’s
dysfunctional too.
Who knows?
Families are so different.
I’ve never met anyone who says they come
from… they thought they lived in a normal
family.
As children everyone thinks their family is
weird and they’re upset by the weirdness
of their own family.
It is a peculiar thing we’re asked to do,
but I think GK Chesterton put it that it is
an onerous responsibility that having been
dropped by the stork down a random chimney
and unwrapped we are invited to get on with
a set of strangers who peer down at us.
You know because although yes, we share the
DNA.
You know they are physically of our flesh
and we are their flesh.
Nonetheless they…
We didn’t choose them.
They are a set of strangers.
There is this man here and we should call
him Daddy and there is this woman here.
We should call her Mummy.
This girl here I should call my sister and
this boy here I should call my brother and
we are somehow bonded for life.
I remember making an absolute…
Well, I wouldn’t say fool of myself.
I was expelled from a meeting of Latter Day
Saints when I first went to Salt Lake City.
I just literally as a tourist I was wandering
around and this person in a grey shift came
up to me and said, “Would you like to see
around?”
And I said, “That’s very kind.”
And then she started gathering others and
then I realized she was a Mormon who was doing
a tour and presumably there was a little bit
of a recruitment going on because they are
very proselytizing sect as you know, the Mormons.
Anyway, she gave us a good tour and we saw
this tabernacle here and this here and so
on and then at one point she said, “I just
want to tell you a little about the church
of the Latter Day Saints.”
And we all politely stood and then she said
how in the afterlife all families will be
reunited.
You’ll be with your families forever, so
I put my hand up and said, “What happens
if you’ve been good?”
And she said, “Could you leave please?”
Because everyone started laughing, but I mean
what a ridiculous idea.
How is that supposed to be attractive that
you’re going to be stuck with every aunt
and every cousin and every…?
Good gracious, every you know alcoholic or
slightly deviant uncle.
I mean Jesus, it’s just the most awful destiny
imaginable and they think that’s a USP.
That’s a…
Yeah, that’s what our church promises.
Good Lord.
Well of course, what it does.
You don’t have to be that smart to spot
is what it does is that church focuses entirely
on women the d’un certain âge as the French
say, woman of a certain age and who have lost
their children because they’ve grown up
and have lost their parents because they’ve
died and they’re lonely and they’ve still
got that family queen bee mother nesting instinct
and they’re the ones the Latter Day Saints
hone in on and say, “You follow us and we
promise you that you’ll be your family all
around you again in heaven.”
And they think that’s a cool thing.
Everyone else would go yuck.
Anyway.
I say and I think it’s true that for the
most, the first moment with Oscar was language.
I was youngish, eleven-ish, twelve-ish, too
young really to be... well, to be entirely
sure of my sexuality or what that sexuality
meant.
I think I’ve always been aware of my sexuality,
but I never quite knew what it meant, but
what I…
So that side of him I would come on to, but
first it was language and I remember there
is a line of Algernon’s in The Importance
of Being Earnest and I was watching the film
The Importance of Being Earnest and Algernon
says to Cecily, “Would you be in any way
offended if I said that you seem to me to
be in every way the visible personification
of absolute perfection?”
And I leaned forward and I…
There were no videos and instant pauses and
on TiVo in those days and I replayed it in
my brain.
“Would you be offended if I said that you
seem to me to be in every way the visible
personification of absolute perfection?”
And I thought how unbelievably beautiful,
the swing, the balance the rhythm.
How clever to make a sentence that’s all
full of Latinate words ending in ation, to
make that sing and poetical because mostly
in the English language the words that are
lyrical and beautiful are not words like the
personification.
They’re rather technical clunky words, but
just simply by colliding them together it’s
funny and beautiful and breathtaking and I
had never…
I’d know that you could use language to
say, “Can I be excused?”
“I need to go to the men’s room.”
I knew that you could to say, “I want some
more.”
I knew that language had that function, but
the idea that it could be used to dance, that
it could be used to delight, that it could
be used to enthrall quite so magnificently
was new to me, so I read.
We had right in the country the library would
come and visit us.
It was what is called a mobile library.
It’s like a big van and it would come about
you know a half a mile from the house and
walk down a country lane to where it used
to stop and get in and that’s where I get
all my books and so I said, “Do you have
any Oscar Wilde?”
And they said, “Yes.”
I said, “I want a play called The Importance
of Being Earnest.”
And they said, “Yes, I think we’ve heard
of that one.”
And then it gets to me and I’m saying it’s
there in front of me and I read it and I kind
of learned the whole play off by heart.
I mean I can still to this day, “Did you
hear what I was playing on the piano just
now?”
“I didn’t think it polite to listen sir.”
And so on and that’s how the play begins.
“I’m sorry for that for your sake.”
“I don’t play the piano well.”
“Anyone can play the piano well, but I play
with wonderful expression.”
And so on.
Anyway, I just became obsessed and then I
saw a biography by a man called Montgomery
Hyde of Wilde, so I read the biography and
this is where it all changed because not only
was this man as I said before, a lord of language,
it’s a phrase of his own actually, but he
was if you’d like a kind of secular messiah,
a Bohemian prince of the most fantastic power
and beauty and grace and gravity and he collected
friends and he looked at the world and he
showed you the true colors of things as no
one had and on top of that he shared what
I knew instinctively was my sexual preference
of my own kind and not only that, but it caused
of course him the most appalling suffering.
He was despised and rejected of man in the
most terrible way and then when I read “De
Profundis”, the letter he wrote to Lord
Alfred from Reading Jail I think it was perhaps
one of the most extraordinary moments of my
life.
Now of course like a lot of people in my generation
that meant I grew up with a sense of doom
being allied to sexuality, that there were
no…
Literature and biography offered no examples
of happy endings for homosexual people.
Gay wasn’t used then.
So I had an immense and obvious sense of the
fact that my life would be doomed, would be
fatal and would probably end in prison or
in shame and something horrible, but the knowledge
that I would be joining Oscar Wilde and then
after that of course through bibliographies
you find out other people you know Andre Geed
or whoever, Michael Angelo.
I would be joining a kind of Olympia of fabulous
men and women who were better than others.
They had a special inside.
They vibrated at art and beauty with a sort
of greater frequency and gave off a more wonderful
harmonic than most people did and so I was
proud to be an elect even if it was a doomed
elect.
That was my sentimental and adolescent I suppose
response to my sexuality.
I can’t imagine how different it would have
been if I had been born twenty years later
into a world of the internet and much more
open things.
I’m sure it would have been a lot less doom
laden, but I suspect I would have read a lot
less literature and I would have been a lot
less interested in the intellect and the life
of the mind.
I would have been much more interested in
just getting my rocks off I suppose because
it would have been easier to do so I guess.
I would have been…felt less guilty for so
long.
There are compensations though for the era
in which I grew up and that is as I say, the
fellowship of literature.
Yes.
I never thought of course when I grew up loving
Wilde and collecting his books and even trying
to collect early editions that I would one
day play him onscreen.
It was simply unthinkable, but it did come
to pass.
I became aware as I entered my thirties that
it was just being shall we say, I was disposed
to the adipose.
I was getting a little plump, that I could
if I grew my hair look a little like him and
although that is a completely irrelevant basis
on which to be qualified to play someone is
it…
It just sets the thing on your mind and the
English player Bennett once stopped me in
Jo Allen’s in London just as he was passing
the table and he said, “I was looking at
you from across the room and it suddenly occurred
to me you look terribly like Oscar.”
“You know, you should play him one day.”
And I thought… and I looked in the mirror.
I went to the gent’s and I looked in the
mirror and I thought gosh and I really didn’t
think much more of it.
Occasionally people would use that tediously
predictable phrase born to be wild and then
suddenly I was approached by Julian Mitchell
the writer and Brian Gilbert the director
and Marc Samuelson the producer who had this
project and saying would I play Oscar Wilde
and it was overwhelming and what was even
more overwhelming was they had as a consultant
this wonderful charming man called Merlin
Holland who was Oscar’s grandson who was
younger than Wilde was when Wilde died and
that connects us to is and it just so happens
that Wilde’s younger son Vivian Holland
married very, very late and had a very late
child and hence Wilde’s grandson lived you
know a hundred years after Wilde was Wilde’s
age, which is rare.
So anyway, that seemed so exciting and novice
and I prepared it.
I read as much as I could of course, but nothing
can prepare you for the…
I don’t know.
Everyday getting up and worrying about whether
or not you’re going to let him down, whether…
I mean the one thing I was absolutely determined
was that Wilde was not just a sort of epigram
factory, just a machine for spouting witticisms
in a camp brittle pea cocky manner going oh,
how to, to utterly utter.
Everyone who described him described the mellow
gravity of his voice, the seriousness of which
he looked into your eyes, which is what made
him so funny because he you know everything
he said was said as if it was absolutely true,
so when it was a dazzling paradox or a mother’s
aphoristic turn of phrase, literal turn of
phrase, you know where the thing is inverted
you know like, “Work is the curse of the
drinking classes.”
He didn’t say it in inverted commas as if
he knew it were a joke.
He said it as if he had just seen it as the
truth and that made it funnier, but it was
also part of his whole manner is that there
was a direct simplicity about him, not an
arch campiness, which is…
So even if I was hopeless I hoped the one
thing I could set straight about Wilde was
that, so that was a heck of a feeling.
Another side to him is of course that naturally
people think of him as a gay martyr and a
gay icon and a gay symbol for the age, but
that he was a marvelous father until he wasn’t,
until of course he created such a scandal
or it was embroiled that the scandal obviously
was disastrous for his family and that betrayal
was not a piece of good father, good piece
of good fatherhood, but while he was a father
he was a kindly father, a loving father and
he created one of the greatest gifts to children
that there ever was, which is his fairy stories,
which I don’t think are well known enough.
I think they rank absolutely with the Grimm
fairy stories and the Hans Christian Anderson
fairy stories.
They’re marvelous tales.
They have all his qualities and something
extra, greatness of heart and the beauty and
the charm and then amazing, I think the word
is proleptic, a sort of prophetic vision almost
of what suffering and pain and sacrifice he
would go through, although they were written
at the height of his happiness and his riches
and his popularity.
There is a sort of doom in the way the stories
play out, which is quite staggeringly as I
say proleptic.
I suppose I mean yes, Wilde teaches us much,
even from a 120 years in the past seems as
true as ever it was.
He wrote marvelously in his essay “The Soul
of Man under Socialism” about the press.
In medieval times they had the rack.
Now we have the press.
He…
I think he predicted really quite brilliantly
the enormous growth of the press, the impertinence
of the press, how wrong it was that the emphasis
on the press was on the individual lives of
private people rather than on sharing truth
and beauty and innovation and I’m afraid
I don’t really enjoy the press at all.
I like to know what is going on in the world,
but that’s a very small part of what the
press delivers, so I haven’t read a newspaper
for fifteen years I think, twelve years certainly
and certainly not a British one.
I just don’t and I find I get on with an…
without them incredibly well.
It is actually not just that it makes me less
unhappy.
It actually makes me actively happier.
It’s as if some huge weight is rolled off
me not to read the opinions of others and
I can quite understand why others wouldn’t
want to read the opinions of me and they don’t
have to and that’s the beauty of it is let’s
not…
But there is a sort of I think a more…
Wilde understood, but there is a sort of furious
anger in certain class of journalists that
they’re not being heard even though they
have access to everyone of their readers the
fact that someone else isn’t listening or
isn’t paying attention drives them slightly
potty and they actually want to bellow their
malice into the ear of the person to whom
it is directed and if they felt that person
wasn’t getting it, it would really annoy
them because they want to hurt.
They actually want to hurt people and that’s
unfortunate.
I just don’t want to be a part of it and
the thing was I was a part of it.
I’m really not speaking as some giant noble
spirit who is easily wounded and must be sympathized
with.
I was a journalist or at least a columnist,
which is not… which is what my objection
is in news galleries.
I was a columnist for several years for The
Daily Telegraph in England which is the most
successful or at least sells the most copies
at least of the serious newspapers and I could
see how easy it was to become this poisoned
figure because the…
You know there is nothing easier than writing
and article against something, which is so
simple.
It writes itself.
You just got to be angry about something and
just got to puff and wheeze with indignation
and fury and resentment and bile and malice
and the thing writes itself and if you write
anything that’s for something it looks sentimental
and cutesy and you know so much… and so
much harder to write, so much harder to write
well.
So all the successful columnists are… certainly
in the British press are vicious and they’re
good at being vicious and admirable and if
you share their politics mostly their viciousness
is something you can applaud.
If you don’t then you just call them beasts
and animals and revolting.
It just gets so annoying.
It’s such a pity and that’s one of the
reasons I love the online world is that although
that exists in abundance you can choose absolutely
which part of the online world you want to
live in.
You can make your own kingdom in that sense,
so things like Twitter or whatever I’m sure
there are all kinds of Twitter you know clusters
of people who have politics that I would find
horrific and really just views that I would
preposterous and impertinent, but I just don’t
have to follow them and I can block them and
I will never know they exist and that’s
glorious.
And similarly as long as you don’t lower
your eyes when reading a blog, as long as
you don’t go down to the comment section
where the trolls lurk, where the viciousness
is because that’s…
I mean there really is just suppurating, boiling
seas of acid where if you just so much as
dip a toe you’ve lost your limbs you know,
just vileness abounding.
Again, there is this resentment, “I will
be heard and not only will I be heard I will
offend.”
“I will tear.”
“I will lacerate.”
“I will wound.”
“I want the sensibilities of anyone who
disagrees with me to be bruised beyond mending.”
That kind of attitude is very strong on the
net and for all that we can be advocates for
the glory and the democracy that exists online
we must be aware too that that dark side of
humanity that just needs to be heard and can’t
bear people like me for example who have access
to greater numbers of followers on Twitter
or whose website gets more hits and the more
they see that, the more the web becomes a
reflection of their view of the meanness and
wrongness of society where somebody will get
it all and others get none and then the more
bitterness there is and I think it’s difficult
because I don’t certainly want there to
be aristocracy on the net.
I don’t want there to be that.
I think that whole beauty of it at its best
is that there is genuine equality and genuine
reciprocity between you know a Twitterer and
his or her followers or between a blogger
and their readers and that it’s not…
You know it’s not an audience going to one
site that is permanent and stable and is like
the equivalent of the old models of the broadcaster,
but that it’s much more fluid and the broadcaster
becomes the broadcasted too, you know the
TV station becomes the audience and as long
as people believe that and behave as if that
is true then there is real hope in the way
information is going.
Who was my first love?
Well I shan’t give you his name because
that’s unkind and he is married and has
children and I wouldn’t want to embarrass
his children, but I’ve given him various
names in novels and in books.
Like a lot of first loves, certainly first
loves for sensitive people such as I was then
I guess I have what I have is called the primary
writer’s arrogance of assuming that my experiences
are common to everyone else’s experiences,
sometimes it is true, mostly one hopes it’s
true and therefore that’s what one likes
in a writer.
You think oh, I feel that too.
Just occasionally you might express a feeling
and everyone goes, “What?”
Then it’s very embarrassing, but I’m assuming
that most people their first love when they’re
teenaged that unbelievable hole that opens
up inside them of longing and yearning, of
pain, of joy, that huge great bundle of toxic
emotions and allied to beauty and opening
out into nature and to glory and suddenly
connecting you with every love poet and every
love song ever written that that explosion
in my head and heart will never be matched.
You can never hope to recapture the first
fine careless rapture as the poet put it,
but it stays with you like a good acid trip.
You know you get a little flashback every
now and again.
It will never leave you and it teaches you
to look at things differently and to feel
things differently.
It educates your soul if you like and all
first love is unrequited ultimately because
it’s so huge.
It’s such an act of giving and it requires
so much back that it can never be given back
and in that you wouldn’t necessarily want
to give them back.
It’s just like a…
It is like an atom bomb.
It is like…
It’s all the energy of who you are and who
you want to be and what you love and what
you hope to be explodes and it is impossible
for a single human being to offer that back
to you in a mutual way.
It would be like matter meeting antimatter.
It’s sort of almost important that what
you do is worship and yearn and long, but
so that was to me of course the single most
important thing in my life and occasionally
I get dreams and I’m back there again and
I’m still as trembly as every I was and
I get… because I’ve written about it I
get emails and Twitters, whatever from people
in you know in adolescence who are going through
the same thing and say, “Oh, I read your
book and it was the same for me and it is
the same for me and he’ll never look at
me, she’ll never look at me.”
“What can I do?”
“I’ll make a fool of myself.”
“Should I write them a poem?”
And, “What if they reject me?”
And, “oh my God.”
And I read that and … You know these vast
sagas, these romantic sagas that are played
out in every school, in every village and
every town and every country in the world.
It’s going on.
It’s all this massive emotional energy just
spreading outwards and some of it is… and
totally unhappily, so the only thing that
saddens me is that the, I suppose the default
community attitude of kids is to suppress
it and to smother it and to pretend it isn’t
there and to be ashamed of it, not because
it’s transgressive or because it’s gay
necessarily.
It’s just as, just as, just as problematical
if it’s straight.
It’s nothing to do with that, but because
the school yard attitude is that you don’t
talk about these things.
There is no…
You know you feel all this emotion, but the
language for it is forbidden really.
You just don’t do it, unless I think girls
are probably better at it and maybe the online
community helps with it.
Chat rooms and things you can express yourself,
but generally speaking boys of fifteen, sixteen
are much more interested in sport or even
if they’re not more interested in sport
and their soul is yearning they’re not going
to say it and if only they could it would
be good.
I suppose ask whether you’re looking to
be loved or to love or whether you really
do because I think you know the risk of using
the parallel of the slightly vulgar or carnal
parallel of the gay community as it is amusingly
called.
Why don’t straight people have a community?
Why don’t you say so what’s the view in
the straight community of dot, dot, dot?
Anyway, you know there is this thing of tops
and bottoms, which I find completely ridiculous
and nonsensical.
But anyway, the idea of passive and active
is an obvious thing we can sort of grasp the
point of and I think that emotionally more
important there is an equivalent of that.
There are…
It may be there are some fifty-fifty people
in the world who want to give love and receive
love in equal measure, but most of the problem
I see amongst friends and I’ve experienced
amongst myself is when people haven’t accommodated
the inequality that they want, they haven’t
understood that their partner wants to give
more love and receive less or they haven’t
understood that their partner wants to receive
more, but sort of give less.
You know what I mean?
And as long as they fit in what they you know
then it’s wonderful, but I think people
talk about one love, but there is the need
to love and the need to be loved are not the
same thing and I suppose that’s… and it’s
working that out is part of growing up.
What makes love last?
I wish I knew.
It can get ill and it gets better again.
I suppose I mean you know awful things that
cliché is that you got to work at it and
communication, laughter.
Laughter is deeply important.
Realizing that flaws are to be loved rather
than to be ignored or denied, that once you
admire and if you love someone enough you
actually love their flaws I suppose and you
hope they love your flaws, but I couldn’t
claim that I have a secret as to what makes
it last.
Hope is another thing that makes it last.
Yes.
I was first diagnosed actually not to my knowledge
as being possibly bipolar when I was about
fifteen.
I didn’t know this until much later when
I made a documentary about my life as a manic
depressive or someone with bipolar disorder,
whatever you choose to call it, an uppy-downy,
mood-swingy kind of guy.
In fact, technically I believe the correct
diagnosis for my condition is psychothymic,
which is like also known as bipolar light
in America, which is rather nice and makes
it sound like a variety of cola, but bipolar
disorder is a mood disorder rather than a
personality disorder such as that might mean
to anybody, but I think we all kind of get
what that is.
To me mood is the equivalent of weather.
Weather is real.
That’s the important thing to remember about
weather.
It is absolutely real.
When it rains it rains.
It is wet.
You get wet.
There is no question about it.
It’s also true about weather that you can’t
control it.
You can’t say if I wish hard enough it won’t
rain and it’s equally true that if the weather
is bad one day it will get better and what
I had to learn was to treat my moods like
the weather.
On the one hand denying that they were there
and saying I can’t…
I’m not really depressed.
Why should I be depressed?
I’ve got enough money.
I’ve got a job.
People like me.
There is no to be depressed.
That’s at stupid as saying there is no reason
to have asthma or there is no reason to have
the measles.
You know you’ve got it.
It’s there.
It’s not about reason.
You don’t get depressed because bad things
happen to you.
That’s getting pissed off and annoyed.
That’s reasonable.
Someone hits you in the face you go ow, you
know that’s… but depression is something
that happens like weather to you inside you
and it’s not about…
It could be triggered by something unfortunate,
but it isn’t…
You know it’s not enough to talk yourself
out of it by saying but I shouldn’t be depressed
because I’ve got people who are nice to
me, which is frustrating for people outside.
They go, “Don’t be depressed.”
“Everyone loves you.”
“You’re really happy.”
“You’ve got a good life.”
I know.
That is what is so depressing.
I can’t help it.
So but once you…
It’s not a solution, but anyway, it’s
very important at least to get that stage
of it out of the way is to recognize it as
a mood disorder as something that is akin
to weather, but the nature of manic depression
or bipolar disorder is it is bipolar.
It is two poles.
It’s not just depression.
The point is that there is this other side
to it.
You have a depressed mood.
You have an elevated mood that is mania, which
is the manic side of manic depression and
these are hypomanic or hyper manic states
in which you can be grandiose.
You can be absurdly extreme in your optimism
and your creativity and your energy.
You can go for ages without sleep.
You can be sexually promiscuous.
You can be a shopping addict, but people have
different ways in which they’re elevated
moods are expressed and they talk nineteen
to the dozen.
They can’t stop thinking, their mind races.
They think they can solve the problems of
the world.
They think they have a unique insight.
It can be a very blissful and exciting and
extraordinary state of mind to be in and then
comes the crash.
The problems of it are manifested in tens.
One is that people, most people outside family
and friends are more annoyed, are more uncomfortable
at the manic phase than the depressed phase.
The depressed person you can deal with because
all they want to do is just sit there and
they want to be in dark in the bedroom sleeping
and not doing any work and just hating themselves
and as long as they’re not you know really
considering suicide, as long as the pain isn’t
that bad then you can manage them whereas
a person in an elevated state is unmanageably
annoying.
They won’t stop talking.
They won’t stop shaking their knees up and
down and getting excited and talking about
things and changing things and re-tidying
rooms and oh, like that.
So you know it can be a very frustrating for
people around you.
At its worst it can be very dangerous.
Obviously suicide is the down side of depression.
I had several suicide attempts in my life,
but also really and this always sounds like
a feeble excuse, but it is true.
The most natural way you would attempt to
cope with something inside you that is affecting
your moods and your energy levels is to intervene
with chemicals to help and because medical
science hasn’t come up with pharmaceuticals
that do particularly well you tend to reach
for the chemicals that are outside the Pharma
counter, i.e. narcotics and alcohol because
they can guarantee your mood more or less.
They like, like the condition itself will
store up a big crash or big reverse, but you
just keep at it and you keep getting drunk,
keep getting wired and you’ll stave off
the inevitable disaster of being alone with
your moods.
So for a long time I was I suppose dependent
is the word on cocaine powder and naturally
when you take a lot of cocaine powder you
tend to take a lot of alcohol with it as well,
so for many years really I never went out
without at least four or five grams of cocaine
powder on my person and I would ingest it
intranasally as was the fashion through the
use of some sort of straw or rolled up currency
note and managed to get by on it.
I never did that when I was working.
I didn’t do it onstage or on while filming
or anything.
It was a way of ending…
As soon as you…
Because work provided its own high, but as
soon as I finished work that was it.
I was out.
I was in clubs and things.
I can’t believe it now.
I don’t know how I managed to do it.
It’s just extraordinary, but I did and anyway,
then I had a bit of a disaster in the mid
nineties.
I was in a play and it just all went wrong
and horrible and I ran for the hills as it
were.
Well actually I ran for Belgium which are
not hills at all.
I ran for the low countries and through Belgium
went to Germany and I was… and so declared
missing by the British for awhile and then
I was found and it was all very ghastly, but
it sort of made me confront the whole business
of this diagnosis and I saw doctors and things
and they confirmed the diagnosis and then
a few years later when I was back on a more
even keel and more used to dealing with things
and a little bit more clear about myself I
made a program about… called Manic Depression
and Me or The Secret Life of the Manic Depressive
was the proper title.
And in which I…
It was two one hour films in which I went
around America and England actually and talking
to people with the problem, talking to doctors,
talking my own history and my own condition
and it was really interesting because it was
considered something of a success this program
and something of a breakthrough and because
aside from all the problems I’ve spoken
about one of the major problems is not the
person who suffers with the disease.
It’s with the rest of the world and mental
health disorder and its stigma.
People just are terrible at coping with it,
other people.
They don’t like anyone mentioning it if
possible.
I had the great pleasure of dinner last night
here in New York with Dick Caveat, the talk
show host of the sixties and seventies, a
brilliant talk show host.
Look him up on YouTube if you don’t know
his… the show he…
I mean he is absolutely wonderful, but his
career was pretty much stalled in many ways
by his fight with depression and he has written
about it superbly and he talked about it and
we were chatting about it last night and it
is that problem of you know say to someone
I’ve got a broken leg or I’ve got diabetes,
particularly if you say diabetes and asthma
say, which are both chronic conditions that
won’t go away.
People go, “Oh, do you take insulin or do
you take that little wheezer thing for your
asthma?”
You go, “Yes.”
If you say I’ve got a mental health condition
they go, “Oh, do you?”
“That’s nice.”
And they want to be somewhere else.
They don’t want to be anywhere near you
and I can understand that.
Of course I can understand it, but you know
that it’s like six degrees of separation
I think.
You know that you know all six of Kevin Bacon
or whichever.
I don’t think that you’re ever more than
three or four steps away from someone close
to you who has a mental health problem and
I think the more we accept that it is us,
it is part of being human then the better
we are because then we can start concentrating
on the things that matter in terms of coping
with it.
It’s a really…
It’s a really tricky business that of diagnosing
children.
On the one hand it is very good if the diagnosis
is sound and you believe in it to spot the
early signs of what could be a very difficult
growing up for a child, on the other hand,
to give Ritalin or powerful antipsychotic
drugs to a child as young as four or five.
I spoke to a professor of psychiatry at Stanford
University.
He is one of the leading people in his field
who is quite prepared to diagnose very young
children as being bipolar, not just ADHD and
things that we’re used to in children and
his point is that non intervention is not
a neutral act.
Not giving someone drugs when you’ve diagnosed
it is in itself allowing the brain as he would
put it to toxify itself, that whatever is
happening as the brain is forming if it is
forming in a bad way, bad pathways, bad neural
signals are being sent and they’re creating
bad pathways as it were or you know bad demands
for you know because let’s face it.
We don’t really understand that balance
between hormone… if you like or hormone
and neurotransmitter, but that’s his argument
is that nonintervention allows the brain to
build itself badly, but it’s a heck of a
thing to give a child as young as…
Well as young as ten or even as young as fourteen
frankly some of these powerful drugs when
the brain is still growing.
I find it tricky and certainly in Europe it’s
considered outrageous, but it happens a lot
in America, but then you have more mad people.
No, I mean sorry.
You have a bigger population and better scientists.
Yes, I’m always asked what was your favorite
city, what was your favorite state.
City, well I love New York.
I just adore it.
I do like Chicago, but I think if I could
choose any city to live in I’d probably
choose San Francisco not just because the
beauty of San Francisco itself.
It’s a great town, but because of its nearness
to northern California generally and there
is so much in northern California right up
through to the Sequoia National Park up to
Oregon the Oregon state line and down below
in also Big Sur area and the vineyards and
you know that part of America is just simply
unbelievable, so I would probably say the
favorite city is San Francisco and maybe northern
California if called it a separate state,
but So.
Cal. as they call southern California has
its charm to, but I loved Kentucky actually.
I loved South Carolina, the lowlands of South
Carolina, Buford.
Montana takes a heck of a lot of beating just
for sheer physical beauty.
The lower of New England is wonderful, New
Hampshire, Maine.
Maine people are so great.
Maine is the lovely…
Down east as well, which is the absolute…
Ironically up east is what it really is, but
it’s called down east and marvelous people,
marvelous, marvelous.
I mean it’s just a hell of a country.
It really…
You’ve got yourself quite a nation here.
The worst career advice I’ve ever gotten
well, is to something because it paid more
money.
I mean it’s…
I know it sounds obvious and cheesy, but it’s
just if you got two jobs and one pays a lot
more than the other and they seem the same
maybe you go for the one with the more money,
but even then I just think toss a coin because
if you go for it for the more money somehow
you always end up paying more in terms of
ease and peace of mind.
Of course one does things just for money and
everyone knows that when you do a commercial
you’re not doing it because it’s a statement
of personal belief, but it’s a fun film.
You try and choose a commercial, TV commercial
that’s good.
It’s made by a good nice people and it’s
a product that you’re perfectly happy to
be associated with, so but obviously you do
those in order to earn time to do other things,
but no, I don’t think I’ve ever been given
disastrous advice.
We’ve mentioned some of my heroes.
Oscar Wilde is certainly one.
I like people who are as unlike me as possible,
which is not an expression of self disgust
or self hatred, but it’s just that you know
you obviously particularly admire things that
you recognize yourself as not having, so ornery
artists, people who speak their mind and don’t
care who knows it because I fear that one
of my greatest faults is my desire to please
all the time and my dislike of offending people.
I think it’s a good thing in many ways.
I’m absolute attacking my own instinct for
politeness, but I think I admire artists who
just speak out or who are strong, so it’s
very hard.
You know if I name them I’ll go home thinking
why didn’t I name this person or that person
and obviously the usual suspects of the you
know.
Your Mandela’s and your whatnots, how can
you not admire them?
But also and this will sound sentimental,
people who live quiet ordinary lives of unremembered
kindness, people like my brother.
I’m not saying he is ordinary.
He is remarkable, but you know he is a reminder
to me of the you know the… just the virtues
of being a good person.
What keeps me up at night?
My minds races with guilt at things I haven’t
done, things I’ve got to do.
Things are always worse in the steady watches
of the night aren’t they?
The things you think oh my God, I’ve got
to do that, I’ve got to do that.
Will I have time to do this?
I better set my alarm for an hour earlier
to do this.
And also if I’ve…
I don’t know.
You know and laziness.
I still feel that I’m being watched you
know by my grandfather or somebody who is
shaking his head at me and going you know
you let yourself down there.
Who would I go to dinner with?
Well obviously Oscar Wilde.
I mean I know it’s just he seems to be the
theme of our conversation, but he would be
a good one.
I’d like to go to…
And I’ll tell you who else.
I’d like to go…
I’d like to meet F. Scott Fitzgerald.
I mean I love his lectures.
I think he writes amazing letters and someone
who is just about the best writer his age
I think, just sentence after sentence were
simply perfectly made and I just want to know
how he did it.
That’s terrible.
I just want…
I mean there are other writers who you know
you could regard as just as great, but something
about him just so technically perfect and
yet so I don’t know what it is.
Whenever I read a sentence of his I think
it’s so simple.
There it is.
It’s in front of me and all the words are
easy and yet just wow and you know from his
letters that he did work very, very hard at
it, but I just want to know where it came
from.